I wrote it I sent it my wife was in the
hospital with our new baby she had just
given birth and I was along with my
other two children that's why I just for
the record 49ers my mother-in-law was
annoying me with her text messages to my
dog's eyes look okay to you was it
diarrhea from the dogs what the man
like I gotta go look at these like
Pomeranians dogs so I texted my wife and
said your mother is annoying me so bad
I'm gonna throw her I looked down and
saw that I had sent that to my mother so
I like to break down panic I realized
what I need to do is that I texted my
mother-in-law and said oh my god I'm so
sorry that text was meant for my cousin
Ben whose mother my aunt Beth is
annoying the outta me she wrote
back like haha I was like I don't know
if I'm in the clear so an hour later I
texted her again dude tell your mother
to lay off you see I put the dude in
there so she wrote back ha ha ha
still not Ben and I was like I did it I
convinced you she won't find out unless
she sees this unsend thing online or
whatever but she can't even really work
a computer protip erase your text
conversations after they're done there's
no reason to keep a log of who you've
been talking to all day that's on sand
you